in this capsule we will start our
exploring the problems of
satisfaction of constraints then
the goal of capsules on
constrained satisfaction problems
it's first to see how to comment
that we can model a problem under the
form of proof of satisfaction of
constraints
we will see and we will learn how to simulate
the king sturge bacteria booth for
solve this type of problem
see also different ways
to speed up the cure of bach tracking
search using among other things to acquire
of inference like euphoria checking and
the ac3 algorithm and then finally one
will see an alternative to tracking
search that will be based instead on the
local search to solve to for
solve satisfaction problems
of constraints so far so far
we have seen that many people's problems
artificial could be formulated as
research problems in a graffiti
with several new each
corresponds to a configuration where a
state of our environment and for
define this graph there we simply have to
define a transition function the
transition function wants to describe us
then will implement final the
properties of the environment
specifically what happens if
I am a given state of my
environment that I do some
action
what effect is it going to see on my
environment
what will be the new state of my
environment after a given action
so that's what the function of
transition into code and to explore the
graff that defines by this function of
transition there that we apply that we can
recursively apply yves-le
for all of us unfold our our
graph to explore it effectively so
we will define a heuristic that will
contain information the specific
to the problems we are trying to solve
to try to solve it the most
effectively possible
now if so it's the close one
took to solve some problems
with the star algorithm for example
and by against until now
when executing a sentry box
fat searches like the guitar
starry was actually opaque by
compared to our application then by
report to the research sentry in
so does the search booth all
what they knew about
clean up is that they were the
leaders who was successor versus
at a given place
but did not know actually commented what
the choice of his new skies tonight
were made that it was all registered
everything at the beginning the function of
completely opaque transition
compared to the search algorithm
in either the problems of satisfaction
constraints are going to be actually a case
particular problems that could be
solve with heuristic research
when we do the algorithms we're going
drink to solve points of
satisfaction against them are going
correspond to particular cases of
heuristic search site even from
particulars in first
constraint satisfaction is that it
is going to be an explicit structure
internal honor in the graph to
explore so they will follow a
particular representation where each 9
years done is a set of
variables or some of these variables
will be assigned certain values ​​and
the transition function so the
transition between them will not have to hold
account of certain constraints the
problem constraints what they are
constraints on the possible values
what can variables take in
all together and in fact making these
notions there two variables of value and
explicit constraints inside
knots that will allow us to
define general ristic waters that
will not be domain specific
therefore rather than at
once we are going to tackle a problem at
see ask yourself the question what would
the good ristic to reuse for this
scope of application there once we
will see translated a problem under a
form of constraint satisfaction
we will not need to do this anymore
work there we will be able to invoke
general solystic to solve so
effective our problem of in the form of
satisfaction include
here are two examples of
satisfaction against 1 the first
would match everything that is game
of riddles an example it would be the game of
sudoku in that if the variables
correspond to the boxes to be filled in
actual values ​​would be the numbers
that can be inserted in anjou box
the docu and the constraints
would match the rules of the game so
for sudoku it would be the constraints
on the fact that in a same in a
same block we can not have twice the
same number
same thing on the rows and so of
after
our class of problems would be
resource allocation issues
an example of taking precise
the development of class schedules for
a rope students in what if our
variable that would be the different
time slots for all courses all
the premises forgiveness or could take place
as soon as more constraints they would
respected it reflects that among others
the fact that only one body can be
assigned to the same room at a given moment
so we can not have twice in the
same local
at the same time given two courses
different also argue that none
student of both courts at the same time
and institutes so that's it we see two
examples of problems that we will be able to
convert in the form of bonuses from
contrary satisfaction